tutti ragazzi li faccio è stava
strozzando tutti ragazzi e per questo
precisa sono fa vj e strano che dopo un
anno e mezzo tre quarti io torni su gta
però quando gioco che i miei amici ogni
tanto facciamo talmente tante cagate che
ho detto vabbè registriamo è quindi
uscito fuori sto video
spero vi piaccia ci vediamo dopo da
ragazzi ciao mi basta prendere con la
macchina c'avete la macchina mi sono
polizia se qualcuno mi venga ebrei
perché sono tra l'altro morto aspetta
che vengo io col giallo
quel che dice la polizia e sono entrato
cioè tre stelle si è fatta dai vai io
spero tu quindi vai ai tipi di cambi
sono ricongiungiamo ci giocasse la
principale ma che cazzo famiglia è la
cosa esageratissimo vita già posso
mancare ci facciamo andare affanculo che
devi selezionare di far avanzare
metterla come selezione cosa stai
facendo
fai qui pare norma travo complimenti era
un acquapark questo meno la lega di
fonduta parti parte veloce soffoca e
falsetti non solo noi e la nuvola luogo
il deragliamento tra il vuoto
scherzavamo si cacciava il vero è che ti
ha scherzato la macchina è anche dato un
cazzotto e propria vita una taglia di
7mila dollari è stata piazzata sì ma che
cazzo è stato e cassetti non abbiamo
incassato niente con importi dei fatti
ti aspetta se devo mandare affanculo
dello dovettero aia perché perché
insomma sei uno straccio di merda mi hai
visto tu la taglia fai scappare
nel mentre io ti segue tentoni
ammazzarvi la famiglia però non son mai
sparare ma perché sei è ricercato dai
100 ai sono andrea potresti andare un pò
avanti grazie
ecco infatti adesso no perché poi questa
cosa brutta ha tenuto picchia come dai
vai vai vai vai su proprio così oggi è
rimasto triturato di bruto e non importa
tra l'altro veramente come hai fatto a
dio che cosa hai fatto bellissimo dio
santo viola jolo jolo madonna di salto
ma come che sarà l'ing
ho visto delle cose che non ti puoi
immaginare arriva arriva
cosa facciamo siamo alla gang del bosco
e modo fork mag
non spiega non c'era armi da fuoco
dipintura venne microfono preferito a
galliani e merda si è cagato piagato
brava brava in riempì questa busta che
deve uscire a c'e la gente magari valico
di stavo guardando le lattine ma conosco
valli questo non ci vedono no no aspetta
non sono io potrebbero pensare che sono
piccioni che si schiantano sulla
macchina giustamente ma che cazzo dici
così facendo sai cagando nei cespugli
allora come vi guardate che mai a
stralcio del cazzo riti tv più le
mutandine di nuovo dai fallo che era
divertente no quella è una pistola ahia
ti ho tirato un pugno adesso scappo aia
sono morto orti temi quanto sei bello ti
somiglia un po alla lontana con due
occhi chiusi è bello che vale
e all'aria che stai facendo queste cose
brutte spiega guarda crisi è fermato il
brasile bellissimo sì poi non so guidare
faccio cacare a guidare tanto abbiamo
tutti la stessa macchina la tragica
perché uno parte iii primo e
svantaggiati simo di prospettare questa
un più bello succhia o non è vero a star
di sé come ha fatto quella rimanere in
gara dove lo zucca va dai questa è stata
bella
metterò una canzone degli 883 in tuo
onore
[Musica]
il die vichiana lo prenderò mai più
danni e quante lunga asta gara spero
poco quando senti nun sai che non puoi
sbagliare una curva che sono a chi entrò
nella no pensate a centrare allora dopo
prima devi marcarli la coda valentino
addosso addosso no c'era un palo di
merda non passi paspardo fermati a via
la decenza di fermarti io ti ho lasciato
passare
ma dov'è che sbaglia dai che sbaglia dai
che sbaglia dai che sbaglia con la mia
macchina rosa penso neanche riuscita
incidentati
c'è uno che vola perché se uno che vola
nella schermata dove danno i premi c1
che vola caso va bene ma che ho
sparatutto aerei volanti sono aerei
susta altro che cazzo è poi qualcosa di
divertente basta fare le seghe
l'espressione che vai bellissima rifallo
[Risate]
per noi che soddisfatto poi come si qui
non so neanche come si pilota questa con
ho mai pilotato una roba così pilota che
moriremo tantissimo moriremo tutti ma
che cazzo succede in tutti e tre sono
primo e sto accadendo
non so dove sono primero sopprimere o el
primero sinceramente fumetti pare che ti
dico commenti parolisi non ho mi sto
schiantando malissimo dopo un ottimo
affare questa grana prove 6 saltati in
aria ma le fa mi capirete minuti non c'è
a me no no no no no no belle o certo con
quale fisica spiega mi ha troppi non
avevo ancora rimosso il carrello dei
timori il boom tutto preso ma perché di
quei non sono affidabili ha ucciso dell
u
ma perché volevo che il carattere
ma questo che faccio cosa sta che faccia
mai visto questo cos'è sta roba
no aspetta cosa succede lo vedi anche tu
quello che vedo io quello lì dietro che
vola no no quello che si aspetta la
macchina 6 banca tissima no vabbè non
posso spiegare cosa succede
la tua macchina parlamente continuava a
lampeggiare come se fosse andato
incontro a qualcosa come se stessi in
cimentando continuamente stragista
grazie porca [ __ ] ti brucio la mano
elicottero generi coulter no io mi tuffo
io mi tuffo ma pensavo a chiederlo noi
invece dello dello riesce
tranquillamente a fare a fare anche
amminare sull'amico sulla macchina com'è
possibile ai a cosa ti ho fatto cosi ti
permetti il suicidio cosa stai facendo
basta fare queste cose
sarà la faccia la fa l'espressione che
fai nel mentre bellissima ri palla
[Risate]
no che figo ha detto quale partito
giugno ahi ahi all anche primo io prima
ho io primo io primissimi sto vincendo
ragazzi mi spiace ma quando il mio
favorito perché perché gli iscritti noi
siamo poveri sconti morto ti devi
tagliere e ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta no sono un [ __ ] vabbè
dai almeno mi fa ripartire da dispero
oddio
mi ha fatto ripartire più avanti di
prima adesso non ha senso va beh non
aveva preso il check point sono
doppiamente sono morto il piano è quanto
è difficile si fa vigente è troppo
vicino sono moltissimo sono in là
dell'oceano
siete volati a carissimo con che
cattiveria di toglierti porca [ __ ] da
york è perché siamo pari 6 chi chi dei
due riesce a salire prima al primo ce
l'ho fatta
e grandissimo 8 giu
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai ormai son
prima non puoi non puoi vincere tu otto
minuti e mezzo fa stare anche più bella
gara bella anche la gara bella e stato
figo donna è visto si porca [ __ ] si è
schiantato un piccione sul muro ok
ragazzi ho fatto una tipo una tipo una
mappa grossa questa super rampo anno ceo
dicendo para un super salto c'è scritto
che bisogna andare lenti sostanza cosa
che faremo sicuramente
cioè io in realtà non ho mai fatto robe
così su gta e la prima infatti sarà un
impatto devastante ma mi sono incastrati
stimo era andare mi posso andare solo
più avanti io quindi angelo ci siete
altre altre 12 gesù madonna è brutta
cosa per me secolo con lo script sul
serio e sa cosa mi colloco questo di
picche mamma succedere e bisogna prima
persona ad esso una specie lamento o mio
dio se vabbè che sei stato si è già
bella battendo in due perché restare in
controllo è solo prospetta che mi ha
accesso sono atterrato perfettissimo a
trovare la pianta a sinistra c'è
ghiaccio era eccomi qua andiamo a fare
le cose
andiamo a fare le cose con questa
macchina perché dopo la già mi sta
inseguendo non so perché tu sei hai la
barba è chi ha la barba in questo paese
non è tollerato stronzo bastardo
prendevamo mandare affanculo perché la
barba per come si fa come si crede
ragazzi il video su gta si conclude qua
ne farò altri episodi perché il
cazzeggio di continuo spero che vide vi
sia piaciuto cose i ragazzi se video
piaciuto suo commento è un mi piace
anche a facili facebook e con gli
adottata descrizione insorti vi
iscrivete mi risulta un solido
no dai
vabbè così la da ragazzi